These days, helmsmen often rely on iron mikes, or Ottos, to stay on course.
But remember that you still have important responsibilities when in the pilot house.
Your vessel's steering gear uses extremely powerful electrohydraulic systems.
It must be operated with great care.
Even though gyropilots do most of the steering,...
...you must sometimes take the wheel yourself.
This usually happens in difficult conditions or emergencies.
Always know which officer has the conn so you know whom to take directions from.
Docking is an especially important task for a helmsman.
Your rudder is not effective at slow speeds,...
...so you must be able to maneuver with the bow thruster.